hello welcome to break through from
science mission I am sadashiva pi and
going to discuss couple of breakthrough
papers published in the week of August
eighteenth let's start first we will
discuss a paper published by to me and
colleagues in science translational
medicine on the mechanism and control of
gastric cancer by nervous system why is
this paper so important gastric cancer
is the third leading cause of cancer
mortality worldwide with a five-year
survival rate of less than twenty-five
percent auto show that vagal nerve which
signals to the stomach through
muscarinic receptors contribute to the
growth of gastric cancers vagotomy can
prevent gastric cancer in mice and there
is the recurrence of gastric tumors in
human patients Botox are anticholinergic
drugs inhibit vagal nerve signaling and
may be used as a safer treatment for
gastric cancer let's look at the data
authors demonstrate that I NS gasps mice
has hired tumor prevalence in lesser
curvature than greater curvature of the
stomach as shown here highness gasps
mice that underwent bilateral avega to
me with pilar of plasti or anterior
unilateral vagotomy showed significantly
less tumors than sham-operated or pilar
a plastic alone pathological score of
dysplasia also showed better results
following PT PP and uvt similar results
are also seen when number of chlorophyll
ative cells are counted to other mouse
models of gastric cancer namely
carcinogen induced n nitroso n-methyl
urea and helicobacter pylori infected
adenosine triphosphatase interleukin-1
be also showed similar results decreased
volume density of tumor pathological
score of 4 dysplasia and number of
proliferating cells after anterior Botox
injection
demonstrates chemical denervation blocks
gastric tumor formation authors also
demonstrate gastric denervation at later
stages also inhibit tumor progression
data is not shown here authors found
variations in gene expression of wind
signaling pathway in gastric tumors
either vagotomy V TPP and UV t or Botox
treatment induced down-regulation of
cd44 in gastric mucosa of my NS gasps
mice vagotomy also reduced the
expression of wind target genes in MN
you treated mice jeene ko expression
analysis showed lgr5 stem cells and
muscarinic acetylcholine receptor 3 in
sorted cells from LG effigy of Pima
stoma but other subtypes of masculine
receptors were little expressed in these
cells also combination of m three
antagonists and chemotherapy reduced
cellular proliferation of the tumors and
m3 knockout mice had less tumor
induction and smaller tumor size when
compared to wild-type controls similar
results were also obtained using in
vitro cultures that are not shown here
author show wind signaling neurotrophin
signaling and axonal guidance pathways
were activated in human cancerous tissue
PGP 9.4 year between protein hydrolase
and periphery in a type three
intermediate filament protein
immunostaining reveals that in humans
neuronal density was correlated with
more advanced tumor stages so this study
provides evidence for the role of
nervous system in gastric cancer and
also a new therapeutic target next let's
look into a paper published by Julian
and colleagues in nature medicine
authors demonstrate that deregulation of
G alpha s may contribute to
medulloblastomas formation why is this
paper so important genetic alterations
driving medulloblastomas initiation and
progression remains poorly understood
authors identify dnas encoding g protein
g alpha as as a potent tumor suppressant
gene ablation of the single dnas gene in
mice is sufficient to induce sonic
hedgehog associated medulloblastomas g
alpha suppressors sonic hedgehog
signaling by regulating both cyclic AMP
e dependent and ciliary trafficking of
hedgehog pathway components let's look
into the data authors were able to
correlate loggia nice expression tightly
with significantly decreased overall
survival within SH group of tumors which
comprise approximately thirty percent of
all material plus tomas authors develop
knockout of gfap gina's minds and all of
them developed material a stoma like
tumors at other stages and the
neoplastic cells were a highly
proliferative as indicated by extensive
expression of ki-67 and was confined to
say cerebellum under percent of gfap
jana's animal succumb to their tumor
around three to four months of age
quantitative rt-pcr confirmed that in
knockout mice expression of ascetic
target genes and pathways components
were significantly upregulated treatment
with NF 449 a selective g alpha s
antagonist resulted in significant
up-regulation of such target genes and
decrease of intracellular cyclic GMP
levels similar result is seen when
constitutively activated form of g alpha
as
is overexpressed data is not shown here
also cyclic a MP rising agent
significantly reduced expression of ssh
pathway proteins while inhibition of
cyclic MP dependent PKA with two
different small molecule inhibitors
significantly increase the expression of
assisted target genes increasing cyclic
AMP levels in knockout mice by rolipram
radius tumor size and proliferation of
tumor cells are also substantially
reduced in addition rolipram treatment
resulted in significantly extended
lifespan of knockout mice g alpha has
was highly enriched at the primary
cilium of GNP s and in the presence of
sha ciliary localization of alpha s was
diminished in granule neuron progenitors
from knockout mice at the tip of cilia
cells exhibited strong immunoreactivity
for GLI to sha downstream effector
whereas gli2 was hardly detectable in
the Y type control GN piece was also
detected ciliary translocation of s mo
seven transmembrane domain protein in
the majority of knockout progenitors
while SMR inhibiting protein p th one
was mainly detected in control GN piece
the tumor cell proliferation rate was
modestly reduced in knockout mice
progenitor treated with cyclic AMP in
the user role eeprom our GD c 0 449
combinatorial treatment with both drugs
caused a greater inhibition of knockout
progenitor proliferation than either
drug alone authors also demonstrate that
various gnas progenitors and mutant
tumors from
months have similar gene expression
signature resembling sonic hedgehog
medulloblastomas so the author's totally
prove the role of G alpha s as a tumor
suppressor thank you for watching
science mission